Washington Post is reporting that the
FBI has James Biden this is Joe Biden's
brother on tape negotiating business
involving his brother the president of
the United States the FBI has these
tapes which means that they were spying
on the guy which means that they've been
investigating them for a long
time the FBI which initially denied
Hunter's laptop which has carried water
for the Democrats we're now finding out
now they they know what's going on with
the Biden family they we know that the
Biden business earned 24 million bucks
between 2015 and 2019 is that for James
Biden's expertise is that for Hunter
Biden's expertise I don't think so
business used more than 20 shell
companies sounds pretty dodgy to me not
very straightforward business and
associat sold the Biden brand what does
this tell us doesn't tell us anything
new about Biden we knew all this stuff
tells us a little bit about the FBI
tells us a little bit about the American
deep state which is just another term
for the liberal establishment the
entrenched bureaucracy